how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU today is
a special day
many of you know scooper Mikey Sutton
Mikey was the scooper that give us the
accurate information about spider-man
during the whole Sony Disney Marvel
Fiasco at the end of the day his inside
sources were right and spider-man ended
up staying in the MCU just like he said
he would
since then he has given us some more
insider info about the Marvel Universe
some has come true already and some were
just waiting on but today is Mikey's
birthday and a big happy birthday to him
and Mikey is so kind that for his
birthday he has given us a gift he's
given us some new information that he
has learned about Iron Man now there has
been a lot of talk about Robert Downey
jr. returning to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in fact there have been many
reports lately that have stated that
Robert Downey jr. has met again with
Marvel Studios about returning and this
was obviously pretty big news Robert
Downey jr. returning to the MCU but we
didn't know exactly how he would but
Mikey's exclusive birthday scoop that he
has for me and all of you today tells us
exactly what he's heard about the studio
planning to bring Robert Downey jr. back
and for those of you worried that they
will undo his sacrifice his death and
everything that it meant don't worry
Marvel Studios understands that they
cannot tarnish the perfect conclusion
and sacrifice that Tony Stark gave so
we'll talk about this report and break
it all down in this video and mikey has
also given scoops to other youtubers as
well I'll put some of them in the
description down below so be sure to
check them out as well and subscribe
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my weekly giveaway
for a chance to win a Captain America
Avengers in-game Funko pop I'll be
picking a winner on Monday all you have
to do is subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below to enter so
here's the official exciting report
about Iron Man from Mikey Sutton he says
the following is a cosmic Wonder
exclusive Thank You Mikey Robert Downey
jr. will return to the MCU according to
my keys inside sources it's more of a
question of when will Robert Downey jr.
return to the MCU instead of will he
return to the MCU when Doolittle tanked
there went Robert Downey jr. zapper
to land another billion-dollar franchise
as well as an indelible character that
would further cement his legacy Robert
Downey jr. wants to come back as iron
man but the complicating part is that
Avengers in game was such a perfect
conclusion for Tony Stark Robert Downey
jr. doesn't want to tarnish it and
neither do the directors the Russo
brothers or Marvel Studios head Kevin
Feige brainstorming for robert downey jr
'he's potential comeback began months
ago before the Russo brothers began to
publicly discuss its possibility Mikey
says that no negotiations have begun
with Robert Downey jr. yet however that
will not be a challenging process all
parties are eager to get something done
but what
well current discussions have swirled on
a future project one which mikey has
scooped months ago secret Wars now if
you followed my channel you know that
I've been talking about Avengers secret
Wars for a pretty long time now I
believe that our next Avengers in-game
level event is going to be Avengers
secret Wars battle world
well according to Mikey's report Marvel
Studios would like Robert Downey jr. to
be an integral part of secret Wars
however not as Iron Man because in game
again finished that story the tentative
plans nothing set in stone yet is for
Robert Downey jr. to be a stark from
another world a representative from the
multiverse for the Illuminati but
instead of saving the planet this stark
will be more of a mentor figure as they
certainly don't want to do a repeat of
endgame it's tricky and complicated
however screenwriters will have the time
to piece it all together now there's
another part to Mikey's report but let's
talk about Secret Wars real fast the
past few times that we've heard news
about Robert Downey jr. possibly
returning I've mentioned Secret Wars
every time because I truly believe that
would be the best opportunity for Marvel
to bring Robert Downey jr. back and this
is because in the comics Secret Wars
involves multiple universes colliding
into one that means you could bring
Robert Downey jr. back but he would be
from a different universe that means you
wouldn't actually be bringing back the
Tony Stark that we know and love from
the main universe therefore you're not
undoing his sacrifice as far as
opportunities to bring him back without
erasing everything that's been done this
is the perfect one now Mikey talked
about the Illuminati appearing and
Doctor Strange and
multiverse of madness way back and in
the comics Ironman is the founder of the
Illuminati and according to him it seems
like Marvel does have plans for Ironman
to be in the Illuminati however the
Illuminati is not going to be from our
universe but again as we know in
multiverse of madness it's going to
explore the multiverse so we can
definitely expect to see people and
groups such as the Illuminati from other
universes or perhaps in the MCU what
they're going to do for the Illuminati
is take one member from each different
universe therefore the Illuminati would
represent the multiverse in its entirety
and the Ironman that would be a part of
the Illuminati would simply be from
another universe this would let him be
able to make an appearance and Avengers
secret wars while also honoring Tony
Stark's death again it's the perfect
plan and it seems like the riders are
trying to figure it out for the future
film and the last thing Mikey has to say
in his report is as for Robert Downey
jr. as an AI voice for iron art it has
been widely speculated he is apparently
open to it but seeks a larger role for
now it seems like they want Robert
Downey jr. to make an appearance in
Secret Wars but stay tuned to see how
the rest of this story unfolds so be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to the
possible return of Robert Downey jr. to
the MCU don't forget to leave a comment
down below and give this video a like
and check out the link below for more of
Mikey Sutton scoops again happy birthday
to Mikey thank you again for this
exclusive and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof